今年高考最大的坑不是分低
而是不懂规则
高分低录
甚至本科掉专科
来来来
你们赶紧把这十个志愿填报大坑记好
志愿填完挨个检查一下
20天讲透志愿填报的一切
今天我们聊志愿填报避坑指南
一定要收藏好了
第一大坑
不看招生章程
很多人填志愿只看学校专业分数线
查了一堆往年数据
却从来没看过目标院校最新的招生章程
结果虽然投档成功
却因为身体条件
单科成绩
外语要求或者其他特殊的规定被退档
你说冤不冤
每年都有同学因为这些要求不达标
招生章程才是高校录取最权威的依据
具有法律效力
所以提交志愿前
一定要把学校招生章程先看仔细了
别让本应该到手的录取通知书飞了
第二大坑
不服从调剂
你所在省份有调剂选项吗
如果你们省是专业加院校的录取模式
那就没有调剂这个选项
只用把充文宝的梯度拉开
老老实实排好志愿就行了
这里要特别提醒老高考和新高考院校
专业组模式的同学
如果你不服从调剂
平行志愿实行的是一次投档
每个批次志愿只能投档一次
万一进档以后
想要的专业前面人都占满了
又不服从调剂
那就只能被学校退档
这一批次的录取直接没你份儿
只能等征集志愿或者下一批次录取
也就是说本科掉专科第三大坑
填报过于激进
很多人都知道冲文宝像个大字
但根本不会用
为什么别人总能捡漏
你却总是冲不上去
因为你冲学校的同时
还非要冲他的热门专业
计算机
人工智能
自动化
电气这些本来选的人就多
你的分数已经在冲学校了
还想上他的顶尖专业
基本没可能
真正好捡漏的
往往是学校里面录取线相对低一些的专业
而且你冲好专业还有被调剂的风险
提前问自己一句
如果被调剂到其他专业
自己能不能接受
记住啊
充文宝要冷热搭配
拉开梯度
保底志愿一定要足够的低
确保能把底线兜住
第四大坑随意填报提前批
很多人觉得报提前批能多一次机会
不填白不填
千万别这么想啊
提前批里面只有各类强基综评
军校
警校定向专项紧缺专业
还有部分高校的照顾专业
一旦你被提前批录取了
档案直接就被提走了
后面所有的志愿全部作废
你连后悔的机会都没有
每年都有人随手填了几个
结果自己被压根不了解学校专业
直接截胡
提前批不是白捡的机会
你填的每个志愿
都必须是你深思熟虑之后的选择
想清楚你真的能接受这条路吗
要是答案不坚定
那就千万别碰提前批
大部分人本科批次里面都能找到合适的
提前批
不报也没事
第五大坑
搞混大学和专业名字
我先来考考大家啊
你能分得清楚哈尔滨工业大学
哈尔滨工程大学
哈尔滨理工大学吗
华东理工大学和东华理工大学呢
北京工业大学和北方工业大学呢
很多学校的名字就差一个字
很容易弄混
专业名字就更容易弄混了
数字媒体技术是计算机方向
而数字媒体艺术是艺术类方向
信息与计算科学听着是不是特别像计算机专业
实际上是数学类专业
生物科学
生物工程
生物医学工程
生物医学科学名字就差那么几个字
学的东西和学业方向可能差别巨大
所以选大学选专业千万别只盯着名字
一定要搞清楚课程学什么
毕业干什么
第六大坑
悟性野鸡大学
如果有个大学名字听起来特别高大上
你会不会默认他是真的大学
很多人就是这么被骗的
每年志愿填报季
总有一些名字特别像正规高校的假大学冒出来
名字起的像不像
再加上一些机构宣传的天花乱坠
不少中低分的考生和家长一直冲动就上当了
结果十几万的学费砸进去
毕业正经的社会根本没人认
最简单的方法是什么
认准教育部公布的全国普通高校名单
不在里面的
直接拉黑
一个字都别信
第七大坑
不看学校条件
很多人被录取时候特别激动
结果进去开学第一天就后悔了
就是填志愿的时候没有考虑学校条件怎么样
生活到底舒不舒服
有些大学在市中心生活学习都很便利
有的在郊区几10km外
交通特别不方便
来回折腾
有的宿舍四人间还带空调独卫
有的夏天连空调都没有
这些不影响录取
但直接决定你未来4年生活的幸福度
建议大家填之前把学校位置
住宿条件
校园管理
交通工具这些都提前查清楚
别等录取通知书到了之后才发现自己被发配
边疆只能慢慢熬过4年
这里我推荐一个网站
大学生活质量指北
里面可以查各种学校这些条件
第八大坑
用手机填志愿
千万别觉得手机方便啊
很多省份填报页面特别复杂
手机上填报界面显示不全
还容易点错漏
看最稳妥的就是用电脑或者平板也行
要是家里没电脑的啊
找靠谱的老师亲戚帮忙也行
如果要去网吧
最好找个独立包厢
打开浏览器
一定要用无痕模式把历史记录全部删掉
千万别保存密码
另外一定要认准官方填报网址
别点各种群里面的陌生链接
陌生二维码也别乱扫账号密码保存好啊
志愿填报期间
各种钓鱼网站和诈骗信息特别多
千万要小心
第九大坑保存忘了提交
你以为自己填完了
其实系统里面只是保存的草稿
并没有真正提交到系统
结果截止日期到志愿直接作废
每年都有人忘记提交啊
最后志愿没报上
之前的所有努力全部白费
整个人当场崩溃
所以我教你一个最笨蛋最有效的方法
填完之后呢
从头到尾检查一遍学校
对不对
专业对不对
顺序对不对
调剂勾没勾
全部确保无误以后再点击提交
提交完之后先别急着关
这个时候一定要截图保存
提交成功界面
截一个志愿确认界面
截一个
很多人就是因为没截图
一直怀疑自己有没有提交成功
焦虑的睡不着觉
第十大坑也是我最想和你认真聊聊的一点
失去决策权
志愿填报可能是很多人第一次
真正决定自己的人生方向
家长会给意见
老师会给意见
机构会给意见
甚至AI也会给意见
你可以参考任何人的意见
但最后按下确认键的人一定得是你自己
因为未来4年是你自己过
而不是别人过
几年以后
如果专业不喜欢
学校不满意
你最难受的不是选错了
而是你会一直想
如果当初是我自己做的决定
结果会不会不一样
所以今天这十大坑希望你一个都别踩
也希望刷到这条视频的你
最终被你自己真正喜欢适合的大学和专业录取
多年以后
当你再回忆起这个夏天
让你骄傲的不是你多考了几分
而是你认认真真的为自己选了一条对的路
官方提前祝你金榜题名成功上岸